Oh
for centuries we Europeans have been
inseparable from the sea it gives us
fish which feed us provide us with jobs
and make us prosper from 2014 the
European Union will do even more to
protect our fish stocks and our fishing
communities we all have an important
role to play as producers vamos a seguir
elasticity pasanda no rookies in the
thunders of apoikia
economy show continued opposition as
wholesalers comprendo van den de pescado
sustainable a Amitabha
as retailers
simply about spell act is mocha broseph
Arab sorry epinephrine fy11 de if
therefore they passing and as consumers
National Board mo golf went on snarling
continues to go battered easy with no
rationing whether it's from the wild or
from agriculture Sifu is an important
part of a healthy diet our choices
affect every aspect of the fish's
journey from sea to plate all of us can
make a difference
every small step to eat buy or sell a
sustainable fish product will help
ensure our children and future
generations remain inseparable from the
sea and the fish it osis eat buy and
sell sustainable fish